recently over on hank green's new
channel sort of new channel journey to
the microcosmos he asked the question
why are desmods symmetrical what
evolutionary advantage does symmetry
give to these little single-celled algae
today i'm going to argue that there is
no evolutionary advantage for symmetry
in desmids just like there's no
evolutionary advantage for the cemetery
in a snowflake instead their symmetry is
what stephen j gould called a spandrel
it is a consequence of their growth and
development it's not selected for it's
just a consequence
of growth
and development now i would say that
these spikes on desmets probably do have
an evolutionary explanation
and maybe they make it harder to swallow
if some other critter wants to eat one
of these the grooves the folds
and the desmood cells i think that these
also serve probably an evolutionary
function they make the cell more rigid
and sturdy but the symmetry of desmonds
themselves here i will argue that's just
a consequence of development
an evolutionary spanned role let me
explain
you are watching science stated casually
with john perry the number one place on
the internet to listen to john the
science educator that's me
ramble aimlessly about the stuff he's
been thinking about
[Music]
today i want to share with you something
that i've been thinking about a lot
lately
and that is how is it that genes
interact with the environment and for a
gene by the way the cell is the
environment its most immediate
environment and then the environment
outside the cell is the extended
environment
how is it that a gene interacts with its
environment to produce the phenotype of
a cell and eventually the phenotype of
an organism that's
a really interesting question i've
actually
i've been thinking about this so much
lately that i even broke down and bought
a textbook on it which i'll be going
through
mechanisms of morphogenesis but i've
started out my in-depth exploration of
this by just
focusing on this genus right here
this is microstereous and the reason i'm
interested in microstereos is that what
what you're looking at is a single cell
this is not a multi-celled organism
it's a single-celled algal organism
and it has semi-cells so each half of
the cell is symmetrical but it has a
really neat intricate phenotype
it's got all these spikes it's got these
grooves and divots on it really really
cool cell how
do genes interact with the environment
to produce
these structures so i've been thinking
about this question for several months
and then i found on hank green's new
channel microcosmos i don't know if
you've seen this yet this is where he
describes things under a microscope
amazing channel absolutely stunning
photography in there and he asked this
question desmids aren't unique in having
some kind of symmetry we see symmetry
all across nature to the extent where
asymmetry might reveal more about how an
organism works than symmetry does
but this kind of mirrored semi-cell
arrangement is particularly striking to
look at and to consider which leads
naturally to the question
why
we haven't yet dug up any scientific
literature that can explain what
advantage this symmetry might provide
though of course we might also be
seeking the simplicity of easy
evolutionary answers when reality is
more complex but if you do have an
answer or even just a guess let us know
because at the moment we don't have any
i can't give you an evolutionary answer
to this i can't tell you what advantage
the symmetry gives this organism what
evolutionary advantage it gives it but i
can tell you
why these things are symmetrical and the
answer comes from watching how they
reproduce
this video is from 2016 it's the nikon
small world in motion competition
this particular clip was submitted by
wim van egmund i'm sorry whim if i'm
pronouncing your name wrong
in this we see that the cell's symmetry
is simply a consequence of how it
reproduces the thing splits in two and
then the two halves grow new halves
and because those new halves grow with
the same genes and under the same
conditions that the adults the adult
haves grew under the parental halves
grew under
you have symmetry the cemetery is just
the consequence
of growing under the same conditions as
the parental half of the cell grew
that's it
it's so simple that it's not satisfying
right
but there's something else that's really
interesting about this video this video
also helps us answer questions about how
genes interact with our environment to
produce phenotype because look at what's
happening
as this cell grows one of the questions
that you might be asking is how is it
that this cell decides where these
dimples will form these dimples of
course end up becoming the grooves that
form the branches and eventually the
branches and the spikes that we see in
the adult cell how is this cell making
that decision how does it decide where
to form a dimple that will end up
producing a branch and then spikes here
in this video we can see quite clearly
that this is just a simple
physical consequence of tension forming
as the cell grows let me explain
so here i got a little drawing of our
organism
and
it's it's in growth stage it's already
there's already been cell division so
the nucleus
is already split between these two
halves and we've got growth
on
this little sucker right here this thing
is growing
and the way that the membrane grows in
the cell wall they grow together because
you've got vesicles that have
cell wall parts in them that are coming
up merging with the cell membrane
spitting that out to grow the cell wall
so you have this constant bubbling up of
things from inside the cell and adding
to the cell wall and the cell membrane
and so you get
basically you get constant growth at
each point
of the cell wall so just to draw that
out here you've got
at each point along this wall
you've got
growth going from the left and to the
right
left
and to the right
and that's that's true everywhere except
except at this point right here
and this point right here
we can't grow on both ways because we're
up against a nice rigid
wall the adult wall
so that means that right down here we
can only grow
upwards
we also have a similar thing happening
up here but to a lesser extent
because where this where these two cells
are attached we have a little bit of an
anchor point so let's just let's just
call all these anchor points
and at an anchor point you can't grow
both ways you can only grow one way
and
there's actually kind of a bunch of
little anchor points up here
because the cells are stuck together
and so there's not much growth happening
here it's very slow
they're stuck together there's pressure
stopping the expansion but you do have
growth outward
so in the middle you have expansion to
the left and to the right and that's
bumping up against the expansion that's
only going in one direction from each
anchor point that causes tension to
build up in this system i'm going to
illustrate that tension with this red
little gradient here so we've got
tension forming there
and at the same time that that tension
is forming so growth is going to be
slower here than everywhere else because
things are packed more tightly together
so we're actually getting the formation
of a new
anchor point it's slowly forming
a point where there cannot be growth
in this case because of physical
pressure
add that to the fact that we have water
pressure
outside this
atmospheric pressure whatever you want
to call it that's pointing
inward
so when you have tension like this and
you could either have it bulge outward
so it could either end up building
outward like that or it could end up
collapsing in and pushing inward well
because we have pressure from the
outside pushing in
this little pressure point in the
membrane in the cell wall is going to
result in a collapse
it's going to result in the formation
of a dimple
this point
we have what is essentially
a new anchor point
we've got a new anchor point right there
as things continue to grow
we have a new point that's going to form
tension right around here so i'm going
to show that again with a gradient
that starts to form there and then once
that pressure gets high enough it will
also collapse and form the next
we will also see a dimple forming up
here that i forgot to draw
so that will end up looking like this
and so on
all of that can be figured out by
watching that little film of course
actual scientists have done actual
research on this as well
here's a really cool paper on this that
models the growth it's called
algomorphogenesis
and
it's funny you know i've i've read a lot
of these papers
and this paper in particular is really
neat and that they actually get a model
a mathematical model to simulate the
growth but i think that they over
complicate it their model assumes that
there's this chemical interplay
there's some sort of morphogenic
molecule that's slowing down growth in
certain spots and accelerating growth in
other spots and i think that you can
just do all that simply by paying
attention to the physical pressure
that's exerted on this system as it
expands under water pressure under
atmospheric pressure i think that's all
you need these guys are over
complicating it but their models are
really nice take a look at this paper if
you if you're interested
i also want to point out that the the
funny little shapes on the tops of these
things those have those are formed
because one cell is pushing on the other
cell as it grows that's why you have
that central shaft and all of these
different organisms that central shaft
is formed because there's more pressure
on that area and it can't grow as fast
as the other areas because it's busy you
know pushing off the other cell as it
grows
so here we've seen a bunch of physical
processes that are determining the shape
of this
cell but i do want to point out that
genes are controlling this but they're
controlling it indirectly the stickiness
of the outside of the membrane the
stickiness of the two cells
to each other as the cells are splitting
apart
that is determined by genes that code
for the proteins that are on the outside
of this cell
and mutations in those genes can change
how sticky that cell is and that will
change
how much pressure there is on it as it
grows and that's going to change how
many spikes there are how many grooves
there are and so on so
this is a really awesome interplay
between genes and environment that
determine that phenotype
i hope you all enjoyed
learning this with me or thinking about
this with me there might be lots of
things that i got wrong in this i mean
this is really just me looking at the
cell and trying to figure out how it
works and then looking at various papers
and seeing what other people have said
so
yeah i'm happy to have people argue with
me about this in the comments
we'll think about this together
stay curious everyone
you